well hello again and uh i'm still in new
york so i'm still happy we're still in
tribeca another day another guest uh we
met with michael green
a few months back but some things in his
world have changed and his world is the
world of passive investing and
probably being one of the world's most
interesting guru types on this subject
of passive investing which
a lot of young investors don't even
think about anymore because we almost
all now invest
in an index or through an exchange
traded fund in the mu as the mutual fund
industry kind of has a slow death uh but
some things as i said have changed in
his world so i'd like to welcome back
the uh the now portfolio manager and
chief strategist at simplify
thank you so i'm gonna have to uh i'll
wait for question number two why don't
you give us a little bit of your
background and what what how how your
career has evolved and brought you to
this moment sure so um i've been
involved in investment markets in one
form or another for about 30 years uh
went to the university of pennsylvania's
wharton school of business when i was an
undergrad i had the privilege of working
with a lot of really talented academics
who later went on and had huge impacts
that was a teaching assistant for gary
gordon who blew up the world in 2008
and
that led me into the early 90s i was
focused on
mergers and acquisitions within
corporate strategic planning departments
so effectively business units that were
being bought and sold
recognized that there was an opportunity
to codify some of the valuation tools
that we used around that
built a software package along with a
bunch of other guys
that ultimately was purchased by your
former employer credit suisse
and it became something called holt
credit source hold which is used still
in terms of the quantitative valuation
tools for credit suisse
that transition happened in 1999 i moved
over to the buy side and initially came
in focused on small cap value working
for a firm up in boston
that's a huge shift yeah huge shift
so my focus was always on the valuation
side and you know that's what i learned
coming out of wharton i became very
facile in discounted cash flow analysis
where alternative ways of thinking about
economic value in eva was the term back
then
um what was really interesting was
transitioning to the markets was was the
first experience that i had moving away
from that theoretical framework was
always a question of how can you more
accurately forecast the couch cash flows
or how can you more accurately calculate
a cost of capital and began to you know
inform me in the actual workings of the
market right so the two are very very
different publicly traded markets people
often think of them as an information
component we often say like what is a
market pricing in so you're going from
as micro as micro can be to his macros
in terms of financial markets yeah no
it's a and i was very fortunate so um i
initially worked
for a firm managing small cap value
funds
was recruited down to new york to manage
funds for royce and associates which is
the largest small cap value firm in
terms of specialists
second only to fidelity in terms of
total small cap assets
and then um was actually hired by a firm
a hedge fund called canyon partners to
launch their new york office and
bring equity expertise over to a fund
that had traditionally been focused
primarily around credit
and was fortunate that that transition
happened directly ahead of the global
financial crisis which created all sorts
of interesting opportunities and allowed
me to actually go back into an area that
i had focused on at the very very
beginning of my career actually when i
was still at wharton which is the use of
derivatives the valuation of derivatives
and coming out of the global financial
crisis what i recognized was that the
changing rules around derivatives had
actually created conditions under which
they were increasingly incapable of of
being properly priced right so the
capital for the arbitration
their careers vanished overnight a lot
of people's careers vanished overnight
um i mentioned gary gordon so gary
gorton is still a professor he's now at
yale brilliant absolutely brilliant guy
um but his models for aig's financial
products were interesting and that they
were exactly correct
except they didn't account for the
prospect that aig would run out of
capital right and so
once aig ran out of capital when an
event occurred that they ultimately
could not pay out
and you can think of this as a kin what
happened in 2008 is kind of akin to
you know we've all had a friend that's
figured out hey if i just double down
every time i lose i can't possibly lose
a blackjack right or i can't possibly
lose at craps well when you run out of
funds you're eventually going to be
taken out of the game right
um so that's really what happened in
2008 was that aig was taken out of the
game because there was a capital call
against them that they couldn't meet and
because were up right before them
correct and so if you actually look at
what happened with lehman brothers the
recoveries against it etc were such that
the pricing of the cds on aig never
would have been justified by the actual
events that occurred but in that chaotic
lack of liquidity environment
the pricing of that cds exploded created
a liability that ultimately aig couldn't
post collateral against
um
that as i said changed the rules of the
derivative game and opened it up for me
initially to go into that space and
again i was incredibly incredibly
fortunate that mitch and josh at canyon
allowed me to have the capital to start
selling derivatives when nobody on the
street was actually doing so
and that largely persisted until 2014
when i left i was given the opportunity
by george soros to manage some of his
capital my own firm
and then in 2016 i began managing
capital for peter thiel
and so famously yeah famously so
um and when i was working for peter is
kind of where
anyone outside of the industry ever
heard of me
there was the events of almageddon the
xiv blow up in february of 2018
and i was fortunate that i was on a
stage in las vegas giving a presentation
about the risks of exactly this event in
2017.
the founder of xiv the etf firm called
velocity shares um just stop and explain
short volatility for just a second
so volatility is um a metric that is
used in the pricing of options you're
effectively trying to understand what is
the potential change in price that it
can occur over a set period of time
right
if you're shorting volatility you're
effectively saying i expect the security
to move less than the market is pricing
okay if you're long volatility you're
saying i expect it to move more and
in general people are short volatility
right almost any investment is saying i
expect something to be stable in the
relationship you don't build skyscrapers
if you think there's going to be
earthquakes on a continuous basis you
don't you know build companies or start
new um uh objectives if if you're you
know uncertain that the economy is even
going to exist in a year or two right
and again so if you go back to 2008 like
many of us looked at 2008 and said oh my
god the world is coming to an end right
so how do you price derivatives you know
the volatility associated with that
that persisted for an extended period of
time by the time we got to 2016-17 and
people had flipped and where i had been
selling derivatives and nobody else was
suddenly everybody was selling
derivatives and in particular
um the xiv and the what are referred to
as the vix etfs xiv was a product that
became extremely popular velocity shares
and credit suisse for the sponsors
and it allowed retail investors through
an etf to gain access to this type of
strategy
the source of the returns for it were
that the markets were much less volatile
than people had anticipated
and when i looked at the characteristics
of what had developed the presentation i
gave in la salle and las vegas
was about the fact that people had
become so crowded in this trade that it
had actually become impossible to hedge
it within its native markets right so
within the vix futures
and you were actually seeing strong
evidence that was bleeding over into the
s p 500 even on normal days right so the
xiv and the related vix etfs represented
about 70 percent of the volume in
volatility markets on a normal day
and it became very clear to me that in
the event that a
more 70 of the volume but what
percentage of
of the value
well um it's difficult to measure
because there's a lot of hidden sources
of volatility selling that exists some
of which have persisted and we saw those
blow up what i'm saying was the 70 was a
great big 70 was huge okay very huge and
the real key associated with it was that
it was doing it in a purely systematic
fashion right so i could predict exactly
what they were going to have to do based
on a change in volatility
whereas as a discretionary investor i
could theoretically post more collateral
right i could say all right i'm not
going to actually transact i'm not going
to do this yep you know i i have a
choice in terms of how i'm going to
behave at least within the normal range
and so what became very clear was that
if an event occurred and my forecast was
effectively that if there was a four
percent change in the s p decline in the
s p
that that would result in a large enough
price decrease in the underlying
security that alongside the derivatives
that existed outside of it that it would
go to zero effectively blow up credit
suisse it wasn't quite go to zero it
would hit what's called the the um
liquidation point where credit suisse
had because they didn't want to expose
themselves to the potential of losing
more money than they actually had in the
product they had set a limit at an 85
percent decline in a single day that
would result in liquidating the product
um
and so i made the forecast that that
would happen on a four percent decline
and this is when again this is may of
2017.
um my calculations where there was
roughly a 95 probability that this would
happen over the course of two years
and just just for context sake and i
know that you know this better than i do
but just for the viewers 2017 involved
54 or 55 days that the the vix
closed in a single digit as a single
digit and the prior year was like 94 or
96 one of those years and that in that
year it closed below 10 like twice so
2017 was the most complacent markets
we've ever seen
so and
the reason why they were so complacent
is because of this supply of short
volatility right so
when you go short volatility you're
effectively providing insurance to the
street to the market
and so when retail participants there's
very famous case of a target you know
manager who actively raised 100 million
dollar fund after success with the xav
which just to put in this in perspective
was up 600 percent in 2017 right so
seemed like this was a no-lose
proposition to people
um when people are providing that type
of insurance all sorts of things happen
right if i'm deciding we see this all
the time in vc if i decide that i'm
going to provide
flood insurance at inappropriate prices
lots of people are going to build houses
and flood plains right they're
ultimately going to put that back on me
um this happens obviously with the
federal government
so when you had that type of framework
it actually created its own conditions
that led everybody to think everything
was going great
but you know line i have become well
known for is saying you know they were
driving uphill with no brakes right you
know you don't even note it you don't
see it right unless you actually decide
that you have to stop right when you're
going uphill the car will stop itself
the minute you start going downhill it
becomes a disaster
and so to finish the story i ended up
getting into an argument in the audience
when i gave the presentation was the
founder of xiv and we ended up getting
into an argument it got recorded
and released to the press subsequently
after it blew up um and so it was it was
kind of fun it was one of those things
where um
you don't often get to do that
it was a lot of fun um
and i you know obviously terrible for
the markets etcetera but that was a uh
that was jay powell's welcoming party
yeah welcome to being welcome to being a
pitcher happened almost immediately
afterwards and so
one of the things that is of course
interesting about those types of events
is that there are hidden echoes of the
fed right so you and i talk on a fairly
regular basis and and
one of the critiques that i often offer
to people in the markets is they tend to
think that the fed is too too powerful
often
they don't realize how powerful the fed
can be
so what actually happened on february
5th 2018
happened on february 2nd 2018.
the fed changed the rules around how the
street had to account for volatility
products
so prior to that event on february 2nd
of 2018 what's called the c car
provisions the capital adequacy ratios
there was an arbitrage that existed
where
if you wanted to hold equities you had
to hold equity capital against that
equity position as a bank
that would survive an instantaneous 30
decline effectively referencing back to
the crash of 1987 right but because
there weren't actively traded volatility
products back then to reference
the equivalent risk as it related to the
vix was only a 10-point jump in the vix
right now those two are totally
ridiculous in terms of the relationship
30 decline in equities in a single day
would lead to somewhere in the
neighborhood of 150 point jump in the
vix right so you ended up having a
dramatic mismatch in terms of of the
risk of the two products and the street
had crowded into short volatility
positions
when the fed changed those rules on
february 2nd and unexpectedly introduced
a 30-point jump in the vix as compared
to a 10-point jump in the vix it set off
a scramble for collateral in the markets
that i was very tangibly able to see
right you felt this as it happened
people were seeking out those who would
be willing to sell volatility in extreme
forms
and you know if you just reverse it into
effectively the effective interest rate
that you could get for you know selling
a bond against that type of dynamic
in the immediate aftermath of that was
like a 75 yield right it was just an
extraordinary opportunity um but that's
you know that was kind of the event that
that created a lot of the interest and
opportunity
as i pushed further into this issue this
dynamic of systematic strategies and how
they influence the market
one of the things i struggled with was
really understanding why markets that's
that historically seemed to be very
sensitive to valuation we certainly saw
this in 2000
had basically ceased to become sensitive
to it so value strategies began to fall
apart things didn't work very well
um
and that's where i really became very
interested in the passive dynamic and
trying to understand what was actually
happening in that space and so a lot of
it actually grew out of that research
that was the initial research around the
xiv that led me to trying to understand
the impact of systematic strategies and
markets
and basically brought me to where i am
today so
and basically brought you to where you
are today uh which is at an exchange
traded fund
firm so
uh
you've got a great twitter following and
i learn a lot i'm sure thousands of
people do as well but
i think we we as a general community
were a bit shocked when that happened
so
one of the things around passive that i
given a much longer conversation so you
know i've presented these materials to
the fed i presented to the bank of
international settlements the imf et
cetera um
part of what i explain to people is that
the dynamics of systematic strategies
and passive strategies actually creates
a fulfilling condition and it's a
positive feedback loop
where the markets are pushed higher by
the transition of money into passive
strategies
and as a result you're basically forced
to actually do passive strategies if you
want to survive
what we had the opportunity to do and
simplify what i've been doing within
hedge funds prior to this was to take
those strategies and modify them by both
leveraging the upside and also
taking advantage of the fact that the
options are improperly priced if my
theories are correct and so buying
downside protection so it's akin to
saying you need to drive that car a bill
right you got to get your kid to school
or you're on your way to a ski trip or
whatever just make sure you have an
airbag or a seatbelt at minimum right
right you probably should check to make
sure that the brakes work um you know
those are all the things that we
ultimately need to think about and
again a regulatory change in september
of 2020 opened up the opportunity to do
that within etfs so prior to september
of 2020
most derivative strategies were not
eligible for inclusion in etfs okay and
presented with that opportunity this is
a great chance for me to actually bring
some of the you know computative skills
right who knows whether they actually
exist
to the retail space and offer people the
opportunity to invest in products that
both allow them to participate
and protect connections
interesting
before we get off the subject of twitter
really quickly i think i'm not alone in
wondering
what's up with with the inconceivable
guy's face who's professor plum
where did these choices come from um
so my twitter handle is at proflum99
okay and my character is my avatar is
vasini from the princess bride
um the prophet 99 actually comes as a
joke from
my time at wharton i started actually in
the phd program and ultimately decided
to bail out but in the early days of the
internet you needed to have something
and so mr green is a character and clue
and prof plum professor plum is also a
character includes so that's where that
in 99 was just because 98 people had
apparently taken it before me right
really i don't know i don't i don't know
the actual number it's just you know
remember okay
um and you know it's it's funny because
that's been an online avatar in one form
or another since the 1990s there were
actually people occasionally on twitter
that reach out to me that interacted
with me on like yahoo message boards and
stuff when it was
still back in the 1990s trying to warn
people about the dot-com cycle
um
you know that uh they're like i remember
you
you know so it happens every once in a
while um but so that's where the prophet
99 comes from the characteristic
princess part is one of my favorite
movies obviously and when um the one
thing that i always try to remind myself
and the reason that that character
resonates so much with me is you know
this is a guy who thinks he's the
smartest guy alive and so
one of the stories that i tell people is
that i've had two very interesting
events in my career and i always try to
be very aware of this
in early 2000s when i started managing
small cap value assets i gave a
presentation to our largest client of
college endowment
this is february of 2000 and i gave the
presentation and said look there's
incredible opportunities that exist
within home builders that are trading
less than half of book value at that
time regional banks in many situations
auto companies were trading at you know
single digit well low single digit pes
two three times earnings sort of thing
um and so i gave this presentation to a
client
and this is like on the eve of the
market
the market blowing up okay and explained
that what was happening was clearly a
bubble in the dot com side
and that there were incredible
opportunities to invest in the
quote-unquote old economy at that time
many of these under-represented
components
if anyone has ever been in these types
of we're referred to as client meetings
or bake offs sort of thing right they
usually tend to have a fairly high
degree of decorum but this was one in
which a gentleman at the end of my
presentation a gentleman stood up and
said
uh this man is the dumbest man alive
is that a quote as a direct quote and
um
it was um it turned the best part of the
story is who that person was right other
than insulting somebody is you know i
was 29 years old at the time
and so i kind of wondered if it was true
but
[Laughter]
grant williams joke is no there's a guy
in phoenix don't worry about it um but
uh the the gentleman who said that was
alberto vilar who you might remember
from the amerindo technology fund going
to jail for stealing from phoebe gates's
grandmother yep yep yep another 1980s
reference etc
and so that's the the reason that i
actually highlight that is
being called the dumbest man alive was
actually very good for me in terms of
forcing me to you know
pause and reflect and say wait a second
what don't i understand
the book into that was in uh the summer
of 2008
where a young hedge fund manager told me
that i think you know mike you might be
the smartest person i've ever met in
this business and while very flattering
i immediately went back to my desk wrote
a note to the partners and like i went
out this is there's something wrong here
if i'm the smartest person and i have no
idea what's going on take me to cash
um and so i i i highlight that because
when i had to choose a twitter avatar
the reason why i chose vasini is because
the character dies because of arrogance
about his intelligence
right
and the real story is that he didn't
understand the rules of the game that he
was playing
so my approach is to always try to
understand the rules better we've all
played an unpleasant board game with
somebody who was an expert in the rules
and you're like wait you can't do that
no no i can't here it's on rule 375
right
unfortunately that's me right that's
what i try to do is basically figure out
a way that people are being forced to do
things
that they might not want to do
so it um
long-winded answer to where does prof
bomb 99 no no but it actually segues
right into
uh you know
because
again as i as i as we started out this
talk because most younger people don't
know a different way of investing this
is how
anybody with 401k for the first time i
mean they're getting into etfs they're
getting into spiders they're getting
into passive funds
but i'm i'm i'm hoping you can just take
us through the nuts and bolts of how
passive investing
worked
10 years ago when vanguard was you know
not you know when indexing wasn't the
end all be all and how that has changed
because in theory there shouldn't be a
change in terms of how passive investing
works well so there's a phenomenal book
that actually just came out
by an ft
reporter robin wigglesworth who's
greatest names absolutely out there
his book is trillions and it's actually
about the development of passive
strategies and etfs and anyone who's
really interested in this i would
strongly encourage you to pick that book
up you know i gotta mention i think page
262 or something like that
and you know the page number
[Laughter]
i i don't think it's actually 267 toward
the back is the point um
but the
the the
dynamic of passive investing has never
actually been neutral and it's important
for people to understand that
the theory behind passive investing
comes out of the efficient market
hypothesis the idea that all of the
information is reflected in the market
that on an individual basis your
prospect of outperforming is effectively
negligible all right
in order to
this
theory
um which was propagated by harry
markowitz and then ultimately by bill
sharp and others
um and eugene fama is obviously you know
notable in his fame for it
the theory was always an approximation
right so none of the tools or ways that
we think about the market are actually
accurate in the context of
passive investing on a purely
theoretical framework so when we talk
about the market we typically think of
the s p 500 right or we think about the
vanguard total market index for example
right
well the actual theory would include
every asset that is in existence this
building that we're sitting in the chair
that you're sitting in
the cars that are now going down the
street we would need to be able to gain
ownership or a share of ownership in
proportion to all of those underlying
assets to actually meet the definition
of a market so we're immediately
collapsing down to a tiny fraction of
the market
the second component is if you look at
all assets right
the dynamics of flow becomes somewhat
meaningless because by definition
anybody buying or selling is just
trading with somebody else right but
when you
narrow it down to a subset of the market
then flow actually becomes an important
component because i can take cash that's
not in the market
and try to deploy it into the market the
process of doing that is going to
influence prices
the degree to which that influences
prices
is
broadly misunderstood
and
the academic research
that was initially done had no empirical
component to it the theoretical
framework for passive investing assumes
that markets are highly what's referred
to as elastic in other words i could put
an almost unlimited amount of money to
work without meaningfully influencing
crisis
this is where the academic link breaks
down versus the practitioner link and
for me ultimately i could never have
figured this out had i not spent 30
years in the markets in one form or
another
where you recognize it like that's just
silly because if i'm trying to put a
billion dollars to work into a stock i'm
going to influence the price of that
stock i'm going to dramatically
influence the price of that sure we're
seeing this with you know increasing
frequency in today's market obviously
and i would point out that part of the
reason that that's happening is because
the passive players
don't react in the way that a
discretionary manager would react
a passive investor
doesn't get any information content when
apple's price doubles overnight
um or you know as a recent example uh
avis car rental right just exploded in
value right
um
a discretionary manager would typically
look at that and say okay well that
lowers the prospect of my future returns
therefore i'm more likely to sell into
that event providing liquidity to the
market
a passive investor in contrast does
absolutely nothing on that information
they don't make shares available when
that price explodes to the top side so
it creates conditions of illiquidity
it's even worse when you start factoring
in the dynamics of flow right so when
money comes into a passive vehicle
and that's where all the money is going
right again this is for me the
opportunity to simplify hedge funds are
stagnant mutual funds are shrinking
actively managed mutual funds are
shrinking
etfs and passive vehicles are growing
and so that flow going in there now
is influencing it because when the price
doubles that next dollar that comes in
treats that doubling in price as if
that's the right answer
and so they will double their allocation
to that stock meaning more money is now
coming so it's like constant validation
it is a system of constant validation of
any price change that occurs
so
you know this is what's happening this
is what's going on in markets it's
creating these conditions that we see on
a daily basis and we're still trapped in
the old framework of saying well what's
the information content here the
information content here is
there's no information right this is
just flows
it doesn't actually tell you anything
about the prospects of avis it can't
bizarrely influence it by creating
conditions under which avis can sell
shares and raise cash all sorts of
interesting things what amc did exactly
as amc did right and so one of the
challenges is how do you think about
this in a regulatory framework right is
this you know if there's not material
public information that has created
these conditions
if i was running amc i'd be raising cash
like crazy too selling my stock because
i know that it's fantastically
overvalued but you know who doesn't know
that it's fantastically overvalued
vanguard yeah right the investment all
of the investors in vanguard and so then
that creates the other frame and you
mentioned going back 10 years and 10
years is actually a really interesting
point to go back to but probably the
right place to start is going back to
1994. okay um if you go back to 1994
passive strategies were about one and a
half percent of the market by market
share
one and a half percent
so all this time
they were tiny
right and today
i've actively managed of assets that are
actively managed in other words within
funds they're now in excess of 50
so over the course of my career the
market share shift has gone from
basically no passive to more than 50
percent right if i look at it in terms
of the proportion of fund flows so money
coming into vehicles
far more than 100 percent of the actual
flows are going into passive under how
you're
what i'm actually referring to is
everybody else is losing money
all right so they're experiencing
redemptions
um in 1994 as passive began to grow
um they began to encounter a problem
called tracking error right so if you're
a vanguard and you're running an s p 500
index fund the worst possible thing is
that your performance deviates from the
s p 500 right it's a no no
as they had grown in size at that point
and became one of the largest asset
managers on the planet even at that
small size of market share
they began to experience problems when
they were trying to buy the smaller less
liquid securities in the market so they
went to the street and they said hey
what can we do about this and the
streets why would you do it that way why
not just buy futures
and the answer is because we're not
allowed to use leverage tied back to the
investment company act of 1940
in order to do futures you need to have
a margin account which requires you to
have access to leverage
which was not allowed under the
investment company act
and the street's advice was we'll just
hire a really good law firm
and lobby the sec to change these rules
and so under the pit sec administration
they change the rules they provided
what's called a no action letter to
vanguard that effectively said vanguard
and all the other index providers that
want to single out vanguard they're just
the largest
um
and said in the simplest terms yeah we
know it's against the law
but we're gonna allow you to do it
because you're just trying to give
america access to the cheapest and best
um you know performing mutual funds on
the planet that's how it sold that's how
it's sold
and that story that dynamic of allowing
the rules to change
permeates the growth of passive
so in 2006
um the rules around 401ks were changed
from a
negative or from a from an affirmation
statement so when you got a job you had
to decide to participate in a 401k you
had to decide to take a portion of your
paycheck and set it aside
the pension protection act in 2006
established they would at the time was
referred to as a nudge component right
where they said instead of being of
opting in you need to opt out that
dramatically raised participation rates
they also made a change where they
introduced something in 2006 called the
qualified default investment alternative
the big complaint about investing in
401ks or the behavior of investors into
401ks prior to 2006 was that they would
often choose to participate but then
faced with a myriad of choices
they would just default to a cash money
market fund which wasn't a huge problem
because people forget that interest
rates were still about five percent of
the time right right um
but
it was ultimately decided that this was
a mistake and so the qdia was introduced
and it became the hr manager's
responsibility to select a fund
all right and that make that the default
investment
the initial choices were largely
balanced funds so a mixture of bond and
equity functions
in 2012 that changed again under
lobbying and became a target date fund
and targeted funds now dominate the
investment landscape for american
retirement they represent somewhere
around 85 cents of each incremental
dollar that now goes into american
retiree funds is going in one form or
another into a target date fund target
day funds are dominated by the vanguards
black rocks to a lesser extent t rover
price capital group
um of the world
they primarily use passive
you know the market share of passive
within target date funds is north of 80
percent
and that's really where everything kind
of went nuts
um because it took away
what people tend to fantasize happens
right so even if you buy a passive fund
or a passive etf it's presumed that
there's an active decision that's being
made there right that you're looking at
the market and saying boy i really think
the market is cheap on this paycheck
therefore i'm going to allocate more
money to the s p 500.
target day funds just took that away and
the vast majority of people don't even
know that they're invested in target day
funds they're called retirement funds or
target date retirement funds right so
you're in the 2035 fund or the 2040 fund
or the 2065 fund if you're younger
you don't really
know what's supposed to be in them you
don't really know how they're supposed
to be managed
all you're aware of is that this is
something that tells you hey this is
roughly when you're going to retire and
therefore this is presumed to be an
appropriate investment for you
that has taken away
the discretionary choice
and created the systematic framework
that's exactly like i talked about with
the xiv where i know in advance what
you're going to do
simply by the behavior of the assets in
your age
that's a really scary place to be when
you look at markets you're like wait a
second this is actually becoming a
deterministics system
so um
you recently had kind of an aha moment
where
you realized that
that there was
an element missing from the academic
work on passive investing
and when you filled in that blank you
ended up
coming out the other end
showing that basically
one marginal dollar of index
investing whether it come from a target
date fund or just somebody buying the
spider
it its impact on the stock market is
actually growing yeah
so this is um
depends very similar again to the xiv
framework right so in financial terms we
refer to this concept of beta
effectively how much does something
change relative to the change in the
quote-unquote market and remember that
market is an approximation
if i'd looked at the xiv's beta to the s
p 500
historically that type of product would
have had a beta or the vix to be more
accurate we had a beta somewhere in the
neighborhood of four to the s p in other
words it was levered four to one versus
the s p
by the time we got to the events of
february 2018 that beta had risen to
about 22.
right so it had become increasingly
levered versus the performance of the s
p 500
that by the way is where i figured out
on a four percent decline the product
would go to zero because it would exceed
four times 22 is 88 and it would exceed
the 85 percent threshold so
the the one of the things i always want
to emphasize for people is the math that
you actually have to do in financial
markets is not that hard four times
twenty yeah yeah not that hard that's
good to know um
the
similar dynamics are
happening in the broader market as more
and more of the money is becoming
effectively rigid and systematic in its
behavior
um in its behavior you mean in how it's
flowing in both how it's flowing and how
securities react to it okay right so
if you imagine a situation where a stock
becomes increasingly dominated by
passive holders who don't react to
information
that leaves less shares available for
people who actually try to trade on
information to trade or have access to
that raises the volatility it creates
effectively a thinly traded stock that
has
what's referred to as inelasticity right
the inelasticity is higher the change in
supply and demand results in a larger
change in price
we're seeing this broadly across equity
markets and when you mention the aha
moment
i want to give full credit to los a
peterson at aqr for a paper he wrote in
that took on the kind of
bible of passive investing which is the
work of bill sharp he wrote a paper in
1991 called the arithmetic of active
management
that created the theoretical framework
for why passive would always outperform
right um on average and then became
accumulated process if you go and you
read you know the bogle uh the jungle
you know chat groups etc which are you
know fantastic a lot of people helping
each other out in terms of retirement
you know they will continually refer to
this paper losses paper sharpening the
arithmetic noted that there were
actually conditions under which passive
vehicles had to become active so when
there's an index rebalancing for example
the inclusion of tesla in 2019
i'm sorry 2020
into the s p 500 that requires passive
vehicles to go out into the market and
change their allocations
okay
what i recognize is looking at lawsuits
work is wait a second it's not just
index rebalancing it also has to respond
to flows it responds to people making
contributions in their paychecks every
two weeks
and so those flows are huge
last year vanguard took in somewhere in
the neighborhood of 400 billion dollars
that's a lot of money even in today's
world right right
those flows matter they influence things
and
recognizing that was a big chunk of
basically figuring this out the second
component
was i was fortunate to figure this out
ahead of some of the academic research
that's coming out but i'm really excited
that the academics are starting to
really begin to explore this issue of
elasticity and markets and the reaction
function to flows in particular i would
point people to recent academic paper by
xavier gabay at harvard and ralph coygen
at university of chicago
in which they introduced what they call
the inelastic market hypothesis and what
they have identified is if you look at
the microstructure of the market the
actual behavior of it that a dollar of
inflows into an index fund causes a
roughly five dollar increase or into a
broader market cause roughly a five
dollar increase into the market in total
now the problem is that they didn't
actually disaggregate active and passive
they looked at the market in total
and my work suggests that that number is
actually quite different if you think
about a discretionary manager like
myself at least historically who would
receive an inflow
i'd say thank you very much for the cash
now i want to figure out ways to invest
it right and so i would potentially buy
something new i would potentially
choose to increase all the weightings in
my portfolio i might choose to hold that
cash because i think that they'll be
better opportunities in the future when
you move to systematic strategies you
take away that flexibility you basically
create conditions under which the money
is forced to flow into the market at
whatever price is available at that
point
and so that five is actually a
combination of money going into active
managers where that multiplier is about
two times
the money going into passive managers
where it appears that multiplier is
currently around 17
and as the market gets more and more
passive that number rises
and some of the crazy outputs from my
work suggests things like if the market
were to go 100 passive
you end up with
valuations that
we would think of as completely insane
right so
in the absence of money coming into and
going out of the market simply by the
process of changing from a market zero
percent passive to a market that's 100
paradoxically you would end up with a
situation where the market grows 50
times not 50 not 5
50 times um
if you add flows to that it magnifies it
so what we have is the conditions
basically an exponential curve that is
becoming more and more extreme as more
and more money flows into passage
so
in a nutshell the more money that goes
into passive the more powerful passive
is 100
all right um
let's pause
skip that thought for a moment and and
bring the fed into
this equip it's this equation how does
fed liquidity play into
passive investing
so this is where i would
caution people to get too excited about
the idea of an activist fed driving
everything
what the fed does do
when they interject capital or they
create conditions under which people
become comfortable that there is a
higher last resort as we saw in march
where you know the announcement was made
that
the fed is going to begin buying bond
funds right they only deployed a tiny
fraction of the money into markets about
eight billion dollars right so again i
understand 8 billion seems like an awful
lot until you inhabit the world that we
inhabit
but that was enough to create conditions
for people like oh my gosh this is
what's driving everything right
there's a couple of interesting
components that play into that the first
is when you create these conditions of
confidence
if you think about the events of march
the easiest way to think about it is
that americans who continue to have
401ks and continue to have jobs continue
to make contributions to those
on a very regular basis right vanguard
has come out as a point of pride and
said less than one percent of our
accounts made any substantive change in
those events right which gives you some
idea how inactive these accounts can
actually be that's a point of pride
and i'll return to that in just a second
so the money flows in
and people are greeting that by saying
fantastic there's buyers of these assets
because i see this global catastrophe
ahead of me so the active managers go to
sell right and eventually you get to a
point where the selling activity exceeds
the buying capacity of passive vehicles
and at that point the market crashes
right you create a liquidity event where
there's no more passive showing up to
buy and so the market crashes
after that event though
once the fed is stepped in and created
conditions under which people like oh
maybe things are going to be okay
the active managers try to redeploy into
the market
and the passive guys won't sell to them
there's no information content for them
so you're now trying to buy back into it
increasingly in the word inelastic
market where that increase in demand is
not meant by any increase in supply and
prices go parabolic
so that's the way i would describe what
happened over the last year and i was
fortunate in seeing this and predicting
that it was going to happen
but i don't really think it's the fed
that much now there are ways that the
fed does influence it right the
provision of liquidity clearly is a
confidence inducer
the lowering of interest rates
creates conditions under which people
can access capital that they can then
use to deploy in risk assets if they
want to
but it also
you know in a bizarre way it can create
lots of problems right so the fed with
its aggressiveness created the last part
of the crash actually from basically
march 12th through march 23rd
um
when they cut interest rates so
aggressively that they cause the blow up
of derivative contracts in treasury
markets on the cboe um
like you know
it's the same phenomenon that we saw in
february of 2018 where the fed made a
good choice but because people had not
correctly anticipated that good choice
you know in an event of distress it
caused a financial market participant i
believe it was ronin capital was the
name of the firm to fail and created an
auction environment in which the
clearing price for treasuries around
march 12 13 was 33 basis points the
minute that auction was over treasury
prices rocket or treasury yield rocketed
back up to 120 bases
that actually blew up all the portfolios
that had chosen to insure themselves
with bonds
so you you you have these feedback loops
and so you know when people talk about
the fed i would highlight
that one they tend not to be
you know the the um all powerful
entities that people think it is really
important setting the price of money
right and it's i have incredible disdain
for the fact that there's 12 high
priests that think they can figure out
the right price for money right that
feel that feels very bizarre to me that
we
and they're becoming higher priests
they're becoming higher they're older
because of the legalization
and because of no it's the the they are
becoming more powerful because nobody
else wants to take control
right so in a power vacuum where
congress won't do its job
where it's debatable whether the
president will do their job
it's very debatable whether regulators
feel empowered
if the fed is the only game in town
they're forced to act and that is what
happened in march 2020. now again the
academic community is starting to wake
up to this target date funds play an
interesting role
if you think about a target date fund
that has to maintain a balance
between asset classes so equities and
bonds for example
when the fed cuts interest rates
what happens to bond prices
they rise
if the fed is cutting interest rates
because equity prices are falling
you have a portfolio that becomes
unbalanced right so the target date fund
now has too many bonds and not enough
equities
and so the systematic collapsing of that
the rebalancing process is actually a
primary source of buying this is one of
the reasons i would argue that we've
seen markets bottom consistently
on roughly the same dates tied around
option expiry and a formal rebalancing
process and target date funds so if i go
back to 2018 the markets plummeted on
february 5th 2018 and then bought it on
march 23rd 2018 and then they bought it
again on december 23rd actually december
26th in 2018 and then they bought them
again in march 23rd 2020 right now we
could all believe that there's some
variant of 13 days after the ides of
march right but that feels very
astrological to me far more likely is
what we're actually seeing as market
dynamics in the presence of very liquid
markets
so
there should be little effect then to a
fed taker
um
again there's the signaling component
associated with it
uh and
the fed taper i would argue it's
there there are some assets that they
have been more aggressive with than
others
um in particular tips right so the fed's
buying program for tips
has been massively outsized in that
market versus other markets
firstly this creates conditions under
which if you think about a buying
program where you are aggressively
buying tips which are treasury inflation
protected securities right
if you're aggressively buying tips and
you drive their price up what you're
actually lowering is the real interest
rate
right
and so what's referred to as inflation
breakevens which is the relationship
between the nominal bond and the
inflation protected bond if the fed is
too aggressively buying tips it
paradoxically tells you that inflation
is going to explode
which was what they were trying to sell
at the time with their average inflation
targeting regime change blah blah blah
which is why they bought more tips than
correct this is actually my wheelhouse
but i know
and so this is this is the sort of thing
that becomes really messed up because
you know if you think about the dynamic
of well the fed is supposed to respond
or look to inflation breakevens as an
information tool and yet they're
actually driving them through their
behavior
then nobody knows what's going on right
i mean like you you really can't
actually tell what the underlying
economic conditions are
um that's
really scary and then they get actual
inflation
on time
and so you know you and i have discussed
some of these things like yes we are
absolutely seeing inflation that is
largely tied to the supply chain
disruptions and a fantastic shift
in buying behavior
so if if we think about what's happened
with the coveted shutdowns people have
been unable to go to restaurants they've
been unable to go to the broadway
theater they've been unable to go to
their local theater or the movie theater
et cetera
they
have reduced their services consumption
in favor of making their backyard a
paradise right or their house of
paradise
so goods consumption has exploded
relative to services consumption
goods have risen in price services have
languished in price
and the outsized purchasing of those
goods a very tangible example of this is
early in the pandemic
everyone remembers the toilet paper
shortages which people freaked out over
right or the price of lumber exploding
right
because people suddenly began doing home
improvement projects
that was caused not because people
suddenly started going to the bathroom
more but because they changed what they
were buying instead of going to the
bathroom at the office or at a
restaurant
they were suddenly all going to a
bathroom at home which meant that the
relative demand for triple ply sherman
versus the terrible stuff that you find
at a gas
station in an office
and we're all familiar with the
distinction
the demand for triple ply exploded and
the capacity didn't exist to service
right so a supply driven disruption
right caused by a changing in the
purchasing pattern created conditions
that should have been met with much
higher prices that have encouraged
people to
brave the gas station despite the risks
of covid to lower their costs of
cleaning themselves right
nobody wants to be accused of price
gouging in that sort of situation so
prices remain the same we weren't able
to ration right we're seeing that
behavior across the economy
part of what i would suggest is also
happening this is that we're seeing the
unfortunate byproduct
of
roughly two decades of industry
consolidation so the private equity boom
etc has created conditions under which
we've dramatically reduced the number of
suppliers of things like industrial
lubricants and toilet paper and you know
everything else so you're beginning to
see corporate america i would argue
taking advantage of the headlines that
was a pretty controversial tweet you
sent out recently yeah it was not well
received on some fronts but others
you know it's unfortunately very true
that what we're actually seeing is i
would argue many corporations taking
advantage of the fears that people have
of inflation say oh well we're just
raising prices because prices are all
going up
if we were actually seeing a cost driven
dynamic
we would be seeing corporate profit
margins retreat right that's not what
we're seeing we're seeing corporate
profit markets expand
and so you know we've had decades of
pricing power as a weapon of mass
destruction when you're making an
economy of monopolies yeah we've created
an economy that is dominated by
monopolies or monopolistic type
conditions
um and that of course is then creating
the predictable conditions that you're
hitting on in some of your observations
where we look at things like automobiles
etc
higher prices destroy demand
and people react to those higher prices
by saying
we're not going to buy stuff buying
conditions for cars buying conditions
for major durables buying conditions for
homes i mean we've never seen anything
like this ever in terms of how depressed
they are
yeah it's it's terrible and if you look
at the
actual consumption expenditures in real
terms they're now actually falling right
incomes are falling in real terms
particularly for those who are
you know more income challenged i guess
i would say they derive their income
from their labor as compared to their
assets yeah inflation is the most
regressive tax for lower income earners
and that's why people are starting to
really get stressed right because
it's very very hard you know and and the
conditions that exist
unfortunately most people actually
intuitively know this sure you can get
that job at the gap and they're going to
pay you slightly higher wages than you
would have you know you would have
received a couple of years ago
but we also know that the investments
are being made in automation that are
ultimately going to reduce the demand
for that labor and those are good
investments to make but on a personal
basis
if you choose to devote your career to
folding sweaters at the gap and they
introduce robots that fold sweaters at
the gap well guess what you now have
unsalable skills
so there's a feedback mechanism that i
think people are really struggling with
that i don't think they're right i don't
think that what you're describing is
recognized yet i think that there are
millions of jobs that are never going to
come back correct
i think that is unfortunately right and
the other dynamic and you know again
this is one of the things that that i
broadly think people struggle with is
when we look at historical data we have
to be very careful in understanding how
it's changed right so one of the
headlines that i'm sure you've
highlighted to your readers and viewers
has been the exploding number of job
openings right the record number of job
openings well
the cost
of a job opening or posting a job
opening has actually changed
the way that it's done has changed has
been changed dramatically if i go back
to
2000 and i wanted to advertise for a job
i would have to take out a classified ad
or i'd have to hire a recruiter to try
to place somebody in this role
as a result and the conference board
would have its help wanted index exactly
so that help wanted was similar to what
we were discussing with 401ks earlier
right it's a positive affirmation i'm
going to pay to post that ad
and i'm going to keep doing it only if
that opening is real right otherwise i'm
incurring a cost for no real benefit
the way the world moves with the
transition to online job postings is
that you actually only pay when
somebody's hired
right so it costs nothing to keep that
job opening out there
and so we have a massive disconnect
that's occurred because the cost of
maintaining those job openings is much
lower than it was historically and i
think that's what it's what's referred
to as search intensity right it goes in
both directions are you really looking
for a job are you really looking for an
employee
and we're chasing job postings in real
time decline
which is astonishing
because
the data that people refer to is so
lagged compared to what's actually
happening on the ground today as demand
really comes down quickly but that's a
different story for a different day back
to indexing for for a minute um because
i reached out to my four closest friends
here in new york and i said so if you're
if you're talking to michael green this
afternoon what are you asking him all
four came back with the same question
when does it stop yeah yeah
um
so
the answer is it's what's referred to as
stochastic right there's a there are
variables in play that we can't possibly
know all the conditions okay
um
but what we do know
is that ultimately withdrawals from
asset markets are a function of the
level of those asset markets right so
wealth is a function of the level of the
asset market okay contributions
are a function of incomes
right if i don't get paid i can't
contribute right and if i raise
inflation then i have less real money if
i lower my real incomes i have less
money to contribute to my savings
so what i would highlight is is it
effectively has its own expiry built in
both for demographic reasons and also
because of behavior as asset markets get
higher and higher and higher people
eventually begin withdrawing
particularly for things like endowments
or non-profits they have rules that
require them to withdraw an x percentage
of their assets
um same rules exist for 401ks and iras
what's referred to as required minimum
distributions which accelerate over the
life so this is this is all these are
also systematic they are systematic
and it you know again
that creates the deterministic
characteristics right now can i know
exactly how many people are going to
have jobs in a year and can i know
exactly what their contribution levels
are going to be no i can't possibly know
that
but what i would suggest is is that as
we become more and more systematic and
deterministic in these flows the end is
unfortunately written in and that's
where it gets really scary because we
see this
in events where
withdrawals happen
in excess of the contributions right
that's the march 2020 story more selling
than buy what's the right price to sell
for an index fund whatever price i can
get right
and the demographic that you're
referring to of course is the baby
boomer generation so they they didn't
have the same optionality
they don't have the same optional
optionality today that they did in
2009-2010 to rejoin the workforce
correct and and you know we're broadly
seeing this right the aging of the labor
force is resulting in these conditions
now the industry is fighting a rearguard
action against this so under the trump
administration in 2018 and i would point
to the fourth quarter of 2018 that
sell-off
which was quite scary for people in a
lot of ways
that's actually a template for what
happens when required minimum
distributions exceed the level of
contributions
and that was the last one right the last
time we saw that because they changed
the rules and they're going to keep
doing this over and over and over again
so in 2018 under 2017 as was changed
became effective in 2019
the uh tjca i forgot the name of what it
stands for but the trump tax cuts and
political terms
changed the age of requirement and
distribution from 70.5 to 72 basically
bought us two years of grace period
they're now talking about eliminating it
entirely so effectively nobody is
required to ever withdraw from the
markets right now predictably this is
happening under lobbying conditions you
can't imagine why that would happen
under lobbying conditions
um but
you know so they're trying to change the
rules again that goes into like i can't
possibly tell you exactly when it's
gonna happen right
but it does have its own expertise built
in and the system does end
and that's well if you're retired you're
living on a fixed income it doesn't
matter what the government is telling
you can do if you have to have income
then you have to have income correct
when you create those conditions
the problem is you know if you have
chosen because in the the language of
the daytina there is no alternative
right i can't get the yield on bonds
that i need therefore i'm going to have
higher equity exposure
well that everybody making the same
choice and facing the same conditions
contributes to this and then when they
go to sell the equity is presuming that
they're actually liquid because that's
the behavior that we have right we've
been driving uphill with no brakes when
people try to get out
it creates extraordinarily adverse
conditions and again this is part of the
point behind what we're trying to do at
simplify we're trying to create products
that allow people to participate
and don't over insure right so every
five percent decline i'm not going to
protect you against that but when you
actually see the really meaningful
events we're trying to design products
that allow people to benefit from that
so the answer is we have no idea
um if i'm giving you an actual date i
mean the one
i think what all four of my buddies
questions come down to is
that between the confidence induced with
by the fed and
the way passive investing works the
combination of the two
seem to make the stock market look like
it's recession-proof
well and functionally it is again
remember like if we go from zero percent
passive to 100 passes market goes up 50x
right that covers a lot of sins and a
lot of recessions and everything else
right um we're never going to get there
because the volatility becomes too
extraordinary and it becomes an xiv type
event where it's like yeah sure it's
going to go up 50x but in the meantime
it's going to crash 95 and then rise 500
right so
those conditions are not actually
investable they create their own
disasters effectively right the risk
becomes endogenous to the market built
into the market
um
but
you know
when you think about
the ideas is the economy recession proof
remember that or the stock market
recession proof right remember that what
the market is responding to is flows and
so when people get fired
because 401 k contributions and ira
contributions are coming out of incomes
if you cut off those incomes
then the market doesn't get the
contribution
and you have demographics working at the
same time so i mean you've got kind of
several
factors that are going to be coming
together right in
coming years and i would i would just
highlight that underlying dynamic right
i think the thing that scares me most
that i hear people say now is oh yeah
the market's totally teflon it could
never go down again
um you know the fed is
you know don't fight the fed the fed is
there for you
um
the fed still believes that the market
is actually sending in a signal whether
that's in inflation breakevens or
whether that's in equity markets they
actually pay attention to this stuff
they really care you know this but far
better than i do in terms of what the
fed dialogue is
if the markets are hitting all-time
highs
the fed's presumption is people know
something right that the market's
telling you the economy is strong
and what i'm telling you is it doesn't
say anything like that right
it tells you nothing about the future
right again you know avis or hertz or
any of them exploding is not actually
telling you what you think it's done so
we we have had a rather active retail
investor
class in the last
in the post-covet era
so how do these retail investors
behave when there's an adverse moment
and
separately i just want to
plant this the seed
fiscal injections this time were
required
giving money directly to americans that
was what was required this time around
not just the not just the fed azure bag
no don't fight the fed it wasn't just
don't fight the fed it was also 42.3 of
gdp in 18 months time yes in cash 100
agree which which again speaks to the
intensity
of people's belief that it's all the fed
no no they were huge fiscal injections
what are you talking about exactly okay
and that's not forthcoming right now
correct and so when i look at the fiscal
impulse effectively the change in what
people receive versus last year
it creates very adverse conditions
moving forward right i mean 2022 we're
looking at a significant negative fiscal
impulse
unless we dramatically expand on what it
doesn't seem is going to be expanded
upon
um
you know that it's a point of concern
for me you mentioned auto sales
deteriorating right sure i know that a
portion of the decline
is a function semiconductors
right
but
if you decide to drive your used car for
another year
because new cars are too expensive
you're actually destroying that demand
right it's not going to pop up and
people are suddenly going to buy twice
as many new cars next year
this is even more true in services
you're not going to eat two steak
dinners next week because you couldn't
meet a state dinner this week right
and i broadly think people are missing
the demand destruction that is occurring
because of the higher
prices and yes when you look at retail
sales nominally things look great if you
adjust it for what inflation is not so
great not so hot and that's another
point that i would make in terms of if
you have rising monopoly power
this is very basic economics but
monopolies produce their characteristic
is they constantly under produce right
so they will under produce versus demand
they're effectively taking advantage of
the fact that nobody else can come into
their market and compete with them
um i think this is going to be a
character and bizarrely enough to have
fewer employees
well they underproduce right so i mean
if production is somewhat still a
function of the number of employees at
least until we welcome our robot
overlords right
um
we are faced with conditions under which
the u.s economy effectively ends up in a
you know what feels like a very
sub-optimal place there okay so
rocket overlords i'm going to robot
robot overlords robot robot overlord
sorry yes i'm going to shift gears for
just a second
um
what happens when when markets go down
again
in this country
income inequality is there's there's
actually been some fantastic academic
work in this arena income inequality
affects economies directly directly
affects economies
what happens when people lose a bunch of
money
again
in this country given where we are where
do you see
where do you see the end point because
you have some fairly
extreme views on this so
the problem with this with
relying on things like defined
contribution plans to pay for people's
extensive retirements
um
we love the idea that we're all
responsible for ourselves right
hopefully part of the message that
people are taking away from this is
actually you're not really that
responsible for the success of your 401k
there's a lot of
you know uh systematic factors that are
influencing the behavior of markets that
i got mike pence fly on my head you had
a mike pence flying your head oh we have
an extra friend in the studio today
anyways
so i can actually feel by mike pence
friend up there
um
the
so
when you think about
the dynamics of that type of a crash
there are people who are going to be
forced to face those conditions by
saying oh my gosh i'm going to i have to
sell because i can't run the risk that
it's going to fall by another 50 but
it's going to fall by another 30 now
what i ultimately think is going to end
up happening is that the fed we're going
to move beyond fiscal injections we're
going to move beyond buying bonds and
ultimately we'll probably see them end
up buying stocks which we just call
nationalization if we're being honest
with ourselves but we don't call it that
right
the second component is that within the
united states this makes me sound like a
communist i understand but
we tend to treat our system of social
support as a function of your employment
right so your unemployment insurance
check is a function of what your last
paycheck was your health care is
provided by the company that you work
for your retirement is a function of the
contributions that are being made from
your paycheck with also your employer
matches right
so
and
because this is all discretionary when
you get fired the company has no
obligation in the form that a
traditional pension would have had to
continue to make you whole in one form
or another right so we have an entire
social network that is actually a social
support network that is predicated on
employment um
when we lose those systems
when those types of systems fail
people don't suddenly discover personal
responsibility they suddenly discover
public responsibility
right and we've seen a lot of systems
when pension systems fail
that's where governments fail
all right so that's what happened in
russia that's what happened in the roman
empire
you know the collapse of the roman
pension system tied to the employment in
the military
was the source of caesar's rising to
power
um
unfortunately i think we're looking at
something very similar here
and i
i don't want to be apocalyptic in that
like i don't have clairvoyance on this
but
certainly the signs are sending us in a
direction that people are increasingly
saying hey the gains were mine but if it
goes wrong it's the public's
responsibility well we we just took
universal basic income on a test drive
for 18 months that was basically what
happened yeah and we got a lot of
inflation to show for it
yeah again i think part of the
inflationary dynamics were a function of
the shifting structure if we had all
universally decided that we were going
to stop paying people for showing up at
work but everybody proceeded to pretend
to go through the motions we might not
have seen the same inflationary
characteristics
but we didn't see that and so we are
seeing the inflationary characteristics
and i think that's important to
highlight
so um
i want to end on two
brighter notes okay
please yeah all right so i'm taking it
pretty dark
i asked the question but so you've been
very involved with an organization
up this way
and you have passionate views about
education yeah so i why don't you tell
us a little bit more because it's an
amazing organization yeah well so so the
organization that you're referring to is
coney island prop um we just did a
conference for simplify where the
proceeds of the conference went to
a donation to coney island prep
coney island prep is a
school in surprisingly coney island
it's charter school that's created by a
friend of mine josh wolfe along with
a social entrepreneur jacob manukin
and they have a very unique view around
how education should work right so
extending beyond the idea of hey let's
just educate the kids and if we just you
know beat them regularly they'll pay
better attention in class we're
recognizing that there's a support
framework both in terms of the families
that are involved and in terms of the
expectations of the children making them
aware right so
we all tend to take for granted that our
kids have exposure to college education
or what it even means to go to college
right so many of the kids in coney
island this is a school where 70 plus
percent of the kids qualify for
subsidized lunches
many of their parents are
first-generation immigrants
they have no exposure to what it means
to go to college and so
they also don't have ski trips we're you
know we've talked about this dynamic
right so you know our kids
go on summer vacation or spring vacation
and it's filled with all sorts of you
know richening exercises we take them to
visit colleges or we take them skiing or
we take them on vacation to foreign
places etc most of these kids have
nothing like that vacation means they
stay home and watch cartoons on
television or on their ipads or whatever
right
so the school instead of taking
vacations in a traditional sense or
holidays in a traditional sense
they will actually take the kids on
field trips to visit colleges for
example right they also begin the school
day at 7 30 in the morning recognizing
that the vast majority of parents
actually need to be able to get their
kids to school and then go to work
um that there's a support system the
school stays open until six o'clock in
the evening it's logical right it's all
perfectly logical we know this we know
that those support systems have to be
created to allow success to emerge the
other thing that happened and this is a
you know just both a function of the
funding that was available as well as
a recognition of the
compounding influence
so coney island started with just fifth
grade and then his kids graduated from
fifth grade they started sixth grade in
seventh grade and eighth grade et cetera
and then they began to move in the
opposite direction so it now goes all
the way through k-12
the
third class has now graduated from the
12th grade
sorry i'm very excited about this um
and they have virtually 100 college
acceptance that's just it's just
extraordinary that's amazing that's i
mean that's
people always say what's wrong and what
can fix it and i always say education
yeah and you know this is the
frustration because a lot of the
language that we use when we talk about
like we can't possibly spend this money
right
people tend to under-appreciate what the
real story of the united states is right
the real story of the united states is
raising human capital right we're all
born with incredible capabilities more
than others obviously
but the ability to raise the individual
contribution to society through
investments in education their
investments in you know
facilitating effective families things
like starting schools early and keeping
them open late so the kids aren't left
to wander the street or the parents
aren't forced to not work so that they
can take care of their kids creating
consistent frameworks and positive
environments for kids to grow up in all
of those contribute to much better
functioning adults
and you know our system of national
accounting we tend to think about things
like gdp as if they were written in you
know on tablets and stone
all of that emerged in the great
depression right so the work of simon
kuznets in terms of national accounting
systems emerged in that time period
and we excluded many of the things that
we should actually include right so when
we talk about a trade deficit for the
united states you know what we're
talking we're counting our goods and
services
but the united states business model is
actually to take the best and brightest
from around the world
and put them to work right i mean people
take risk having children in india or
china or you know brazil or mexico they
raise their children they make all the
efforts and investments that are
required to do that and then the most
successful among them come to the united
states and we don't show that in any way
shape or form in our accounting system
and as a result we get terrible policy
well um
this is all true and we can hope for
better leaders and younger more
charismatic leaders uh maybe you'll run
for office one day i highly doubt it but
well that brings me up to my last
question so um you've done so many
different things in your career what
what what do you want to be when you
grow up
uh eventually i want to get old no um
look at the i have been really blessed i
mean i'm just i've been incredibly
fortunate and
if i'm very honest about where i am in
my life i've got my youngest child who's
now graduating from high school
i have flexibility in a way both in
terms of my career and you know personal
finances etc that allow me to explore
other things so i become more active in
terms of advisory roles to the us
government to the regulators et cetera
try to share as much information as i
possibly can
publicly about the risks that i see
but you know if i'm fast forwarding 10
years off into the future or 15 years
off into the future grandfather that's
what i want to be
so
good answer great answer
well um
thank you again for spending so much
time we went into overtime a little bit
but that's great that's wonderful
because we got to learn about these kids
in coney island who actually can dream a
dream which is that's awesome for kids
who
before they couldn't dream and dream um
but we look forward to getting back
together with you maybe in a year or so
thank you so much for every all of your
education and i'm sure people are going
to have to google some terms that's fine
um that's how we learn but thank you
again for your time i really appreciate
it thank you danielle i enjoyed being
here
[Music]
you